- Oh, Emma, Vorsicht!
- Hallo, Papa!
- Hallo, Lisa!
War die Woche schön bei Tante Lisa?
- Ja! Das machen wir jetzt öfter.
- Ja klar!
- Herr González. Wie geht es Ihnen?
- Es geht mir gut, danke!
- Hallo, haben Sie Nicos Tasche gefunden?
- Leider nicht.
Aber ich hab' den Fahrradladen gefunden.
- Was?
- Ja. Es gibt zumindest eine Yara
González, die einen Fahrradladen hat.
- Ja, das ist sie!
- Der Fahrradladen ist
in der Adalbert-Stifter-Straße 43.
Das ist im Zentrum
in der Nähe vom Arbeitsamt.
- Und?
- Ich war da.
Das ist der Laden auf dem Foto.
- Ja!
- Und wie kommen wir da hin?
- Zuerst fahrt ihr mit dem Bus
bis zum Grafenplatz.
- Mit dem Bus zum Grafenplatz.
Okay, den kenne ich.
Und weiter?
- Dann geht ihr über den Grafenplatz
und kommt in die Krugstraße.
- In die Krugstraße?
- Ja, genau.
Geht die Krugstraße entlang,
überquert die große Kreuzung,
dann geht ihr am Theater vorbei
und an der nächsten Ampel rechts.
Weißt du wo?
- Ja ja. Das ist nicht weit.
Am Theater vorbei und
dann die zweite Ampel rechts …
- Hm, noch mal …
- Nein Papa, schon okay.
Ich schau im Handy nach.
Also, gehen Sie bis zum Grafenplatz.
Biegen Sie dann links in die Krugstraße.
Überqueren Sie die Schlossstraße
und biegen Sie an der nächsten Kreuzung
rechts in die Adalbert-Stifter-Straße.
- Okay!
- Alles klar! Los geht's!